[Music]
Colin Firth's wife made a shocking
confession this week Livia's ug Olli
revealed that she once had an affair
with a man who she later claimed was
allegedly stalking her in a statement to
ET Firth and his wife of nearly 21 years
confirmed the affair that is said to
have occurred between 2015 and 2016 a
few years ago Colin and Livia privately
made the decision to separate during
that time Livia briefly became involved
with former friend Marco Brancaccio the
First's have since reunited the
statement continues quote mr. Branca
carried out a frightening campaign of
harassment over several months much of
which is documented Brancaccio denies
the accusation telling British paper The
Times quote she filed a complaint
against me for stalking out of fear that
I could go public with what she had
revealed to me about her marriage and
work adding quote Libya wanted to leave
Colin for me birth and his wife were
married in 1997 and have two sons
together 16 year old Luca and 15 year
old Matteo
[Music]